hey guys my name is Jonah welcome back
to my gay mentioned series so last time
we talked about the entire scope of this
series and warnings up who were doing
make sure you watch that planning video
there and as I explained in that video I
don't really want to be planning too
much too quickly in the beginning
because I mean I actually would like to
kind of do that I would like to have
just ten episodes of just planning and
just figuring everything out because
this is such a large project you like
you guys have to realize just how big of
a project this is but anyway because
that would kind of be boring and I also
have to kind of balance the
entertainment versus production kind of
balance I guess of this entire series
we're actually gonna dive in and start
writing code like today and then as
things creep up we're gonna plan for
them then and there and because of that
because that kind of iterative model
that we're gonna do hopefully we'll get
stuff actually happening as soon as
possible and that way you guys will kind
of see results and it'll be more
entertaining but also it's a really good
web development that I personally also
really like because instead of just kind
of spending ages building up the older
kind of foundation and then like a year
later seing a triangle on the screen we
kind of get to we're able to get to that
stage a lot faster and this is just kind
of it's it's better to see if what if
what we're doing is even going to work
in the first place and then we can
always kind of improve it anyway without
much further ado um I was spending this
entire week kind of planning this series
and that's why I kind of just just
realized exactly how much is involved
here and there's a bunch of like
opinions that I really want to share
with you guys in probably the coming
weeks because the way that we do this is
going to kind of impact the series
because we either see something on the
screen quickly or we wait longer and
then get benefits further down the line
but anyway again I don't want to talk
about planning today so that's just kind
of just some loose things on my mind
today we're gonna set up everything so
we're going to set up a github
repository we're going to set up a
visual studio solution and projects
we're going to set up the configuration
for that to some extent and we're going
to just kind of link those two link
everything together and make a simple
obligation that prints hello world to
the screen but it will be kind of
structured and configured correctly for
our actual game engine so the question
might be well okay if you're gonna make
hub repository if you're going to make a
visual studio solution what are you
going to call the engine the engine is
going to be called hazel hazel engine
don't ask me where I came up with that
from I kind of liked us going through
various nuts or something at work and
there was like walnuts and hazelnuts and
stuff like that and I really liked
hazelnut and hazelnut might end up being
like the level editor or some kind of
component of it but I just think hazel
really nice simple name and I don't
think there's any other game engines
called hazel so hazel that's the name of
our game engine yay congratulations
that's actually probably the hardest
part is coming up with a name
anyway now that we've done that let's go
ahead and make that repository okay so
here we have my github account it's just
github become four slash the channel
here it is you following me here what
I'm gonna do is just make a new
repository I love the fact that I'm
doing this in front of all of you guys
I'm gonna call it hazel I'm just gonna
say hazel engine for now as my
description it's gonna be public of
course I'm gonna initialize the
repository with it readme it for the
good ignore we weren't worried about
that the time being and for the license
I'm going to give it the Apache License
2.0 for me now basically that just means
that if someone uses this they have to
disclose it who dis in fact the hazel
engine as well as as well as like other
kind of things like if they modify the
source code that also needs to be kind
of documented anyway that's kinda basic
setup now in terms of github and where
all this code is going because I get
asked this all the time
the car's gonna be 100% free and public
anyone can use it just as long as you do
state that it is the hazel engine that
you're using which i think is fair it's
gonna be 100% public every old cars
gonna be online so you don't need to
like be a patron or anything but
speaking of which I do want to thank all
of my patrons because this series would
not be here without you guys so if you
want to support this series and
everything I'm doing you can go ahead
and go to patron compost after the
Cherno you'll get videos like a week
early so videos for this series you'll
get a week early and then there's also
many other benefits to do with this area
specifically for example whilst all of
this actual code that we write in each
video is going to be public for everyone
no matter if you're a patron or not I do
actually have a private kind of
development branch where I've already
written like a good chunk of the engine
like probably I'd say the first 10 to 20
episodes of
we already done and already available as
of this video going public it's already
available for all patrons and like I
mean that's that's just there right
because obviously this is a huge engine
I don't know I can't type everything in
front of you guys so the stuff that I
kind of do in my private time when I
actually plan and actually write that
code to see how everything is going to
fit together all of that so basically a
working engine does already go up on
that private github repository for all
of my patrons so that's enough that's
another way that you can kind of help
support em and in return of course get
something as well that being said though
the beauty of that is that the page ones
get to see the code before it gets
written in the video which means that if
there's problems with the code or there
suggestions people want to make they
actually end up contributing and
actually helping like basically
influence what code actually Zirin in
these videos so again huge thank you to
everyone for that because that's really
really cool anyway let's stop talking
about that let's get back to creating
this repository okay so this looks
pretty good I'm just gonna hit create
repository and there you go the hazel
engine repository that's really cool I
wonder if anyone's gonna notice it's
actually becoming public because
obviously at the time of a recording
this video I haven't actually put out
the video yet and yet there's a new
repository the script off so that's kind
of interesting you can start the
repository of course by going here and
that way you'll kind of know about
changes and all that stuff it's kinda
like favoriting it and it helps support
that as well but we have a license and a
readme file pretty bland so now that
we've got all of this we can kind of
clone this using git and actually create
a visual studio solution and that will
be all great now the way that I like to
do this because either Visual Studio or
get will end up complaining about
certain things being already kind of
there so in other words if you try and
make a you try and clone get if you try
and clone and get a map repository into
it directly that's not MTA will complain
if you try making visuals gif solution
into a directory that's not empty that
might also not work so what I like to do
with this is just hop on over to Visual
Studio
I'll hit file new project I'm going to
make an empty C++ project it's going to
be called hazel now of course we will
have multiple projects in the solution
but I just want the solution name to be
hazel and I'm just going to put it into
seed dev it's usually a good idea to
actually
your kind of source for your parent
development code into a repository or
rather into a folder that isn't tied to
your user account so in otherwise I'm
just doing si dev it's not kind of you
know see users Yamcha knockoff or
whatever nothing like that
and then also I want to note here that I
don't have any spaces in the namespaces
can sometimes conflict with certain
things not all plugins like spaces I'm
looking at a certain Android like
plug-in by a certain company anyway
doesn't matter the point is try and
avoid spaces as much as possible in your
actual names at least leading up to the
actual kind of root folder of your
repository here we have C dev and then
hazel and I want to create a directory
floor solution and then I'm just gonna
hit okay so there we have it the hazel
solution pretty cool if I just open this
kind of folder so that we can look at it
we have a folder called hazel inside we
have hazel the hazel solution file and
then inside that we actually have a
folder called hazel which has a project
called hazel so there's a lot of hazel
everywhere but that's kind of the idea
now what I'm gonna do next is basically
just open a command prompt window by
typing in CMD here and I have I do have
git installed so all I have to do is
type in git clone HTTP github.com slash
the chanter slash hazel and that's it
now of course hey will doesn't exist
sorry I forgot that I'm already in here
so we can just call it like not a nerd
git or something it's just gonna clone
it into a folder I don't really care
where it is because what I'm gonna do
next is actually go into this folder I'm
gonna make sure that I look at hidden
items this is the dot git folder that we
care about and I'm gonna cut this and
actually put it into hazel over here
right and then delete that git folder
now this is what we end up with so
basically what I've done is I've managed
to cloning that git repository into a
folder that was not in fact empty and
you can see that this contains our
license and readme file that we created
kind of through that github repository
but then we've also got all of our stuff
here which is also really important I'm
sure there might be a better way of
doing this but this is just the way I do
it I'm not a big deal basically all we
want is we want create a visual studio
solution and a git repository in the
same directory so I've done it manually
like that okay cool anyway now that's
done we can move on to actually setting
up our project so what I have here as
you can kind of see is essentially a
hazel project file and then a hazel
solution now our solution is going to
contain more than just the engine right
hazel is our engine what we want to do
is actually build that into a dynamic
link library into a dll right on Windows
at least is going to be a dll file and
then what we want to actually do is
create some kind of external application
project that will be an executable so on
Windows a dot exe file and then we want
to actually link that engine into our XE
file now there's two ways of doing this
primarily you could use a static library
or you could use a dynamic library
myself plus series has an excellent
video about the differences between
dynamic and static linking and also all
about dynamic and static libraries so
check that out if you're not sure what
the differences are basically the reason
that I'm choosing to go with a DLL apart
from the fact that we can kind of load
on and unload it as we kind of choose
it's primarily because we we're gonna
have quite a lot of quite a lot of
dependencies quite a lot of libraries
that we actually have to linked into our
engine to make it work if we go with a
static library and we ignore the fact
that you can kind of create fat static
libraries that's kind of dodgy so if you
look at traditional static linking
basically what it means is that all of
our dependent libraries that we have we
actually have to link that into our game
our engine might depend on certain
libraries but we need to link instead of
being able to link all of those
libraries into the engine kind of
library file we actually have to link
everything into the game if that makes
sense again static linking is that's
just how it works whereas a DLL is
basically like an exe file so we can
actually link everything into them and
then our game will just depend on that
single DLL file which will contain
everything it needs instead of having a
billion other kind of library files so
essentially what we end up doing is
actually linking everything into that
engine dll all about kind of
dependencies which means they all need
to be static libraries so we link all
those static libraries into our engine
DLL and then we link that engine dll
into our game and that is it that's all
we need so that's what we're gonna
Mikio someone a right-click on hazel hip
properties these are our properties now
since my feelers talk a little bit about
platforms and configurations we have to
kind of configurations to start off with
debug and release we can make more
further kind of as time goes on we will
make more but platform is something that
I want to particularly spend some time
on because if I go to the configuration
manager here we have two kind of
solution platforms x86 and x64 now I
don't really want to support 32-bit
because it's kind of it's 2018 like we
32-bit is not something that I want to
support maybe for legacy reasons it
might be a good idea so I might riad it
back if like people do make the case or
if someone really wants it but for me
right now I don't 1 x86 so what we're
actually gonna do is come down here into
edit and remove this x86 platform
entirely ok it's gone we also need to
remove it from here because it's also
been created here so edit win32 same as
x64 in terms of visual studios namings
and then that's it that's done so this
kind of keeps everything a lot cleaner
we're going to got one platform now x64
and then still two configurations debug
and release since by configuring this
I'm gonna go to all configurations I'm
gonna change the configuration type this
is the big kind of change from AFC to
DLL write dynamic library that's very
important change because now instead of
this building an exe file it builds a
DLL I'm gonna keep the Windows SDK where
it is as well as the visual shear
version at 2017 which is V 141 so it's
very important that you guys download
Visual Studio I do have a video on how
to set up C++ on Windows I suggest you
watch it that I didn't want to spend
today setting up and installing Visual
Studio I think you guys should be
already pretty familiar with that this
is quite an advanced series and if I
start doing things like telling you how
to install visual studio we'll be here
for decades so please look at my other
videos for what kind of tips I guess
also help with setting up C++ in general
but that being said visuals should be
2017 we are going to primarily target in
C++ 17 so lots of modeling
there and we definitely need Visual
Studio 2017 for that support so the two
other things I want to set up here
really are the output directory and the
intermediate directory because Visual
Studio is default set up is not very
good if you're gonna look at my video
that I'll link up there which is kind of
the best way to set up C++ Visual Studio
Projects this is gonna be kind of based
on that but I've changed a little bit
certainly what we want to do is this is
all fine but I kind of want to make a
folder in the solution directory called
bin everything is gonna go there
everything all of our binaries all of
our libraries all of our kind of
projects that we have in the solution
everything is going to go and bin and
I'm actually going to separate this by
the actual configuration so I'm going to
say configuration which means debug or
release in this case and then a - or -
and then the platform okay so this will
be something like in this case debug you
know x64 I don't want to spent want
split this up into two different
directories cut it because I don't want
like this massive folder hierarchy and
then in this case it's just going to be
the project name and that's it right so
what this is gonna do is for this hazel
dll file it's gonna put it in bin-debug
debug x64 and then hazel dot dl
oh sorry and then hazel and then hazel
dot dll and we'll leave a splash at the
end of that I want to copy this and
paste it into the intermediate directory
now there's two ways that I kind of do
this you can just add another folder
called bin int but I don't really like
having too many folders at that core
kind of brute solution directory so what
I do is I end up just kind of doing bin
and in slash end which just stands for
intermediates so these are kind of all
the files the visual studio needs to
create like the obj files for example
when it's actually compiling our code
definitely safe to delete once has been
compiled we don't want to put into the
same directory as being necessarily bomb
because bin has kind of all of our
actual stuff and in fact that's why I
don't like doing this in fact I might
not actually do this because it's nice
to just be able to copy and paste that
bin folder and it has everything you
need so I might just say bin you know -
until something like that which just
basically means that I can delete that
directory if I want and if I just want
to copy and paste bin somewhere because
I want all my binaries I don't have
actually manually go in there and delete
the intermediate directory to kind of
keep the file size low so this actually
might be better okay
cool there we go that stuff is all
pretty good let's hit okay
next thing I'm gonna do is right-click
on my solution file and hit add new
project now here I'm going to add an
actual game project basically so we have
our engine but now we need an
application that will use our engine so
I'm going to call this sandbox and it's
just going to go in to see dev hey we
might move it into a directory further
along the way like you know examples or
like sandbox projects or something like
that once we have a few but for now
sandbox will be fine okay
now once visual sugar creates that I
want to copy a lot of the settings from
here so of course it's made its own
platform which is really annoying and we
might actually have to do this every
time I shadows later but we'll get
because we're using visual Studios
templates but we'll get rid of x86 again
quickly
hazal should still be fine yeah and then
we'll get rid of win32 okay that stuff
is gone all configurations I'm just
going to copy and paste this output
directory and then also this
intermediate directory and then of
course sandbox will actually be an exe
file okay cool and that's really all we
have to do for now so let's hit OK
I'm gonna set sandbox as these startup
projects and furthermore I'm actually
going to do something now that is going
to save some headache probably in the
future I'm going to just open the
solution directory and then I'm gonna
control v 2w well controller double use
my keyboard command but I'm basically
going to close that solution file close
solution is the actual thing that I did
that I'm gonna actually open the
solution file I just realized that
that's going to not open it as a text
editor so let's open a text editor and
take a look at this solution file I'll
open it with Visual Studio code okay so
I'm looking at the solution file here
and basically all I'm gonna do is I'm
actually gonna shift this sandbox
project from being the second thing in
this list to the first one what that
means is for people who kind of
check out this repository fresh from
github sandbox is actually automatically
going to be the startup project instead
of hazel
because if Hazel's the startup project
it's obviously not gonna run its a dll
file but this way they can just
literally open the solution hit f5 and
everything will run so there we go
that's done so I'll open this now of
course for us if we have a dot vs
directory with user settings it's going
to remember like which one we left as
the startup project so that's all kind
of easy for us okay awesome so now let's
actually set up a basic enough structure
so we have sandbox and we have hazel
what I want to do now is just kind of a
link these two together someone I
right-click on sandbox go to add and
then reference and then I'm gonna add
hazel as my reference what that means is
that now when hazel actually compiles
and generates a static library file and
a dll file this is going to actually
link with that so hazel is going to be
linked into sandbox but it's done for us
kind of using visual studios interface
if we right click and hit properties go
to linker command line and then look at
debug for example you can see here that
if we look through this command line we
have this line right which says see dev
hazel bin-debug X in situ for hazel
hazel dot Lib okay
so it automatically links for us that
engine library file now you might be
like well didn't we make it a dll file
why is it a Lib file it's because when
we compile the dll file in Visual Studio
it actually generates both a Lib file
which contains kind of every function
that we've actually exported from the
DLL file so that we don't have to
manually actually Lourdes functions or
symbols from the DLL file and then it
also generates that dll file which has
the actual machine code and any other
kind of link stuff as well so that's why
we basically can statically link against
hazel lib but the DLL file is what we
need for a long time okay cool anyway
that's how that works
looks pretty good to me let's hit okay
that is it that's our project set up now
I'm going to quickly go over here to
hazel and hit the show all files button
I'm going to add a new folder called SRC
which will contain all about source code
I'm going to do this
for sandbox making sure that we're on
show or Files mode because we want to
actually create that says directory on
disk and then over here I'm just gonna
add a basic header file which is going
to be called like literally I'm just
going to test this out now because we're
already at like 20 minutes and I
definitely wanna save the actual code
writing for next time but I'm just going
to make test dot H and test dot CPP I'm
going to write a basic function here
namespace hazel and then void print I'm
going to include test dot H namespace
hazel void print is going to print F
hello world or rather let's just say
welcome to hazel engine that seems a bit
more appropriate will include stdio.h to
get that printer function and then what
we need to do is actually add eckle spec
DLL export that function however we are
going to need to include it as well into
sandbox so this is gonna be a little bit
rough because again I don't want to set
this up properly we will set this up
properly next time we'll talk about DLL
exporting and importing and how to
actually get our library set up
correctly with the hazel API so we'll
talk about that next time
but for now we'll simply a dll will
export that print function from here
we'll hit right click build on the hazel
dll now you can see that what's happened
is if we go into hit the hazel root
directory we have been we have two about
x64 we have hazel then we have a hazel
DLL file and a hazel Lib file so that
dll file is needed to actually run our
code but the Lib file gets linked in to
sandbox so that it knows which functions
are available
and where they are in the DLL let's hit
a new item in sandbox I'm going to call
this application dot CPP this is just
going to include well when I'm actually
going to include anything I'm just going
to type in void main' which is our main
function
okay and I just want to call this void
print now what we're going to have to
actually do is for now copy this paste
it up here call this deco spec DLL
imports avoid prints from the hazal
namespace and then I'm just gonna call
hazel prints just like that okay and if
I right click and build sandbox you
should see that we don't get any linking
errors or anything like that it's done
if I try and run it though it's not
going to work because it's going to
complain about that DLL file actually
missing so again for now we're gonna
automate all of this in the future but
for now just to show you guys how this
works I'm going to go into bin a debug
x64 Hazel's copy that DLL file that
we've built manually put it alongside
sandbox at exe and now hit f5 to run now
that worked we can go any errors let's
put a breakpoint here so we can actually
see what's happened if I hit f10 and I
look back on our console you can see it
said welcome to hazel engine which we
did from within that dll file so there
we go
we're up and running next time we're
gonna continue on and actually write
some basic engine code and maybe even
write the entry point of our engine
alright so that's it I hope you guys
enjoyed this video you can see that it's
probably getting a little bit long
already and I kind of want to keep this
between between 10 and 20 minutes so
we'll see kind of how we go because
inevitably as we get into more
complicated things it's gonna be hard
but everything that I kind of showed you
here even though at the end might seem
like I kinda just took a few shortcuts
to get stuff working there is no I like
doing that it's because you actually see
how things work right instead of me kind
of setting up automated steps that do
everything for us you can actually see
what manually needs to be done so that
when we do automate it you know what's
actually happening but we basically did
some very important things today we
created that hazal dll file like project
write and an actual sandbox project the
links with hey Google
we set up again our repository we set up
a visual studio solution everything is
ready to go for us so that next time we
can actually dive in and start writing
real engine code so that's the setup
done right that's all we need to worry
about for now I promise you and then
next time I'm gonna continue on and
actually start writing some engine code
which I'm really really excited about I
hope you guys know this video if you did
hit that like button you can help
support this series by got a patron of
course - they sure know those people
already have the next video up which is
really cool so if you want to see that
engine code today well you can and it
really does help support the series and
I'm so thankful for you guys because
this would not be here without you all I
can't wait to see in the next video
goodbye
[Music]